[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا انا ميسون نويهد واقدم
لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده نبدا بابرز
العناوين
في تصريحات للعربيه روسيا تتعهد بافشال
هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد وقائد فاجنر يتمرد
على قرارات بوتين للمره الاولى
في السودان العربيه توثق مشاهد ماساويه
لشاحنات تحمل الفرين من نيالا جنوبي
دارفور هربا من الصراع الدائر
قبل زياره مرتقبه لبلينكن الصراع الامريكي
الصيني ينتقل لاعماق البحار فكين تزاحم
واشنطن في عالم كابلات الانترنت
بعد محاكمته التاريخيه في قضيه الوثائق
السريه الذكاء الاصطناعي لاحق ترامب
والجمهوريون ايضا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من روسيا ففي تصريحات
للعربيه اكدت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا تهدف لوقف اراقه الدماء فيست
الذي استمر لثمانيه اعوام متعهده بالقضاء
على الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاده زخروبا
اشارت الى ان عده دول قدمت رؤيتها في
مبادرات لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه والمبادره
الصينيه هي الاكثر تماشيا مع نهج موسكو
نتائج الايام الاولى من الهجوم المضاده
على روسيا تزامنت معها موجات تفاؤل تصدرت
التصريحات الاوكرانيه اذا حتى الساعه
استطاع الهجوم المضاد استعاده سبع قرى
شرقا وجنوب اوكرانيا وابرزها بلهودانتي
نسكوتشي
التقدم الذي اعلنته كاف يمنح نحو خمسه
كيلومترات فقط للقوات الاوكرانيه التي لا
يزال امامها نحو 90 كيلومترا للوصول الى
ساحل بحر ازوف وقطع الجسر البري الروسي
الى شبه جزيره القرم الجيش الاوكراني
بدوره اكد ان قوته تتقدم باتجاه مدينه
الشرقيه البلاد كخطوه لاستعاده بقيه
الاراضي في نفس الوقت اقرت كيف بخسائر
فادحه في العتاد بعد ان اخرج كمين الروسي
رتلا من مدرعات برادلي الامريكيه ودبابه
من العمليات فيما عرف بمقبره الدبابات هذا
وتؤكد موسكو ان الهجوم الاوكراني الم ضاد
فشل وتم احباطه ولم ينجح في اختراق خطوط
الدفاع الروسيه نتيجه جاهزيه الجيش
[موسيقى]
تفاؤل حذر عبر عنه امين وعامل
بخصوص الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد وقال ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحرر المزيد من الاراضي
لكن لا يزال الهجوم في ايامه الاولى
انه ليس على يقين بعد ما اذا كان هذا
الهجوم قد يمثل نقطه تحويلا في الحرب ام
لا
نلتقي هنا بينما تشن اوكرانيا هجوما مضادا
كبيرا لا يزال في الايام الاولى ولا نعرف
ان كان سيمثل نقطه تحول في الحرب لكننا
نرى ان الاوكرانيين يحرزون تقدما ويحررون
المزيد من الاراضي نعلم ان المزيد من
المكاسب تزيد قوه اوكرانيا على طاوله
المفاوضات وكلما زادت مكاسب اوكرانيا زاد
احتمال ان يدرك الرئيس بوتين انه لا يمكنه
الفوز في ساحه المعركه وعليه التفاوض على
سلام عادل ان التقدم الذي نراه على الارض
يوضح ان الدعم الذي يقدمه حلفاء النيتو
يحدث فرقا حقيقيا في ساحه المعركه
لم تلبث
الدبابيه الخروج من مستنقع الوحي الذي
استمر طويلا واعاق حركتها حتى اصطدمت
بالغام روسيه مزروعه بكثره فروز قاموا
بزرع الالغاز الاوكرانيه بنسب تجعلها احد
اكبر حقول الالغام في العالم بحسب صحيفه
ليموند الفرنسيه وفقا للقوات الغربيه تغطي
الالغام المزروعه حاليا مساحه تقارب 170
الف كيلو متر مربع اي ما يعادل سته اضعاف
مساحه بلجيكا لكن المصدر نفسه قيام الروس
بزرع كل هذه الالغام موضحا ان الاوكرانيين
وضعوا الكثير منها قبل الحرب الاسيام في
دومباس حيث يتقاتل الطرفان منذ عام 2014
الهجمات الاوكرانيه الهادفه للعثور على
نقطه ضعف في خط المواجهه الروسي لم تسر
كما ارادت كاب مع صعوبه تحقيق المكاسب
جنوب اوريكاف والتخلي عند دبابات غربيه
بعد تدميرها في ساحه المعركه كما يتعين
التغلب على مشكلتها الاساسيه اذا ما ارادت
التقدم على خط المواجهه والمتمثله بنفس
الطائرات المقاتله بينما تنتظر بفارغ
الصبر طائرات افسده عشر من حلفائها
هناك قلق غربي في اوكرانيا ولكن من نوع
اخر الخطر النووي المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافايا الجروس لفت
الى خطوره تدمير
من التاثير المحتمل الذي يمكن ان يحدث على
محطه الطاقه النوويه
عند تدمير الست تنخفض مستويات النهر
والخزان بشكل مضطرد وهناك حد لا يمكننا
بعد ضخ المياه الى هذا الخزان والقنوات ما
يعني اننا سنكون تركنا الماء الذي بداخلنا
لن يكون هذا بالضروره سببا لخطر مباشر
لكنه وضع خطير لانك مقيد بالمياه الموجوده
لديك
ينضم اليها البرلمانيه الاوكرانيه
اهلا بكم معنا في حديث خاص لقناه العربيه
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه ماريا خروفه قد
تعهدت بافشال الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد وان
هذه العمليه العسكريه على اوكرانيا هي
لوقف الدم في دومباس مدى تردون عليها
مرحبا اولا
من تصريح من روسيا التي تدعي بانها تسعى
لوقف اراقه الدماء بعد خمسه عشر شهرا من
شن هذه الحرب
ونسمع بان اقاويلهم بان الهجوم
المضاد لن ينجح هذا بمجرد اضغاطي احلام
هذه هذا الحرب التي قامت من خلالها القوات
الروسيه بضم جزء من اراضينا استطعنا
استعادته جزء منها اكثر مما كان يتوقعان
لذا لقد بدات العمليه المضاده للتو وبدات
بشكل جيد ما قد يحدث يوم الغد لا اعلم هذه
حرب ومن الصعب التنبؤ بها لكن من الواضح
ان روسيا غير قادره على تحقيق اهدافها
التي زعمت بها
والان ما ياملون به هو ان يتم الانسحاب من
الاراضي التي سيطروا عليها هذا ما يرغبون
به ونحن نود ان نعمل على تحرير كافه
اراضينا وسوف نحقق هذا الغرض سيد جون
شارينكو بالنسبه لهذا الهجوم المضاد حتى
الان نتائجه وتيرتها بطيئه وهذا ما يقلق
الغرب الذي يقدم لكم الكثير من الاسلحه ما
هو سبب هذا التقدم البطيء برايك هل هو
مثلا قله في العتاد العسكري المتواجد
لديكم ام هناك مشكله مثلا في الاستراتيجيه
ام حقيقه روسيا هي قادره على مجابهتكم
بهذا الشكل
لماذا هي بطيئه مره اخرى اوكرانيا وعلى مر
سبع ايام حررت اراض اكثر مما نجحت روسيا
في قدمها طوال السنوات الماضيه
ولهذا لا يمكن ان نقول انها بطيئه فنحن
لدينا نتائج ولكن لا نعلم ما قد يحدث يوم
الغد لكنها ليست بطيئه
لا يمكننا في بضعه ايام ان نقوم بطرد
القوات المحتله وتحصين المناطق التي تم
احتلالها من قبل الروس لمده سنه تذكروا ان
روسيا كانت تعد العده للدفاع عن هذه
الاراضي في بلادنا منذ اكثر من سنه لذا
لقى العمليه المضاده ليست بطيئه بل اراها
ناجحه واكثر مما
من ما هو الحال بالنسبه للعمليات الهجوميه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا منذ سنوات
ان المبادره الصينيه حتى الان هي الاقرب
الى النهج الروسي هل هذه المبادره ما زالت
يعني مقبوله منكم ام ترفضونها بشكل تام
بايجاز لو سمحت
نحن نود احلال السلام ونود بالتوصل
لمفاوضات سلام باسرع ما يمكن لكن ما نود
من مفاوضته هو ان تتم التحرير اراضينا
بصوره كامله وعلى روسيا ان تغادر اوكرانيا
هذا كل ما لدينا لا نرد اكثر من ذلك اي
شيء نود ان نستعيد هذه الاراضي وان تقوم
روسيا بالانسحاب من اراضينا وبعدها سوف
نفاوض اما اذا كانت المفاوضات عن تخلي
اوكرانيا عن بعض اراضيها فهذا لن يكون
واردا هذا سوف يكون امرا كارثيا ليس فقط
لاوكرانيا بل النظام العالمي برمته وهذا
سوف يجعل لا يمكن ان يكون امرا مقبولا ان
تقوم دوله باحتلال اراضي من دول اخرى
البته شكرا لك هذا البرلمانيه الاوكرانيه
اوليكسي جونكو
ليست اوكرانيا حقيقه المشاهدين من تواجه
ازمات في هجومها المضاد حتى روسيا باتت في
خطر الانقسام اكثر من اي وقت مضى قائد
فارغين الذي يوصف بطباخ بوتين يبدو ان
خلافه مع القاده العسكريين الروس امتدت
تبعاته ليصبح صداما مباشرا مع بوت اتضح
ذلك حينما رفض بريغوتين مجددا توقيع عقود
مع وزاره الدفاع بعد يوم من اعلان بوتين
ان الاتفاقيات ضروريه يبدو ان تصريحات
تحمل تحديا لكوتن نفسه ففي تصريحات امس
ايد بوتين دعوه من وزاره الدفاع للمقاتلين
الذين تصفهم بالمتطوعين في اوكرانيا
لتوقيع عقود مع القياده العسكريه فيما
ينظر بجوجل لهذه الصفقه على انها وسيله
لتاكيد السيطره على المجموعه التي تجمعها
خلافات قديمه متجدده معقده الجيش بسبب نقص
الذخيره والاسلحه ايضا
عندما شاركنا لاول مره في هذه الحرب لم
يقل احد اننا سنكون مضطرين لتوقيع صفقات
مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لا احد من مقاتل فاجنر مستعد للسير في
طريق العار هذا مره اخرى لهذا السبب لا
احد منهم سيوقع العقود
وفي اخبار الساعه بعد لحظات نتابع المانيا
تشارك الولايات المتحده مخاوفها وتحذر من
خطر الصين السيبرانيه
[موسيقى]
نتابع اخبار الساعه من شان السوداني حيث
قال مدير الاعلام في حكومه اقليم دارفور
موسى داوود ان عدد القتلى في مدينه
الجنينه بولايه غرب دارفور بلغ اكثر من
شخص مشيرا الى ان القتلى ينتمون الى
الطرفين المتحاربين في المدينه وهما قبيله
المساليد المدعومه من قوات الدعم السريع
وجماعات من قبائل العربيه بالمنطقه واضاف
داوود بان كل المؤسسات الصحيه الان في
المدينه خرجت عن الخدمه تماما
هي مشاهد تلخص حجم المعاناه التي يعيشها
العشرات من سكان مدينه نيالا جنوب دارفور
شاحنات وسيله اجره في كل مكان
وحقائب تنتظر اصحابها بانتظار الانتقال
الى وجهات قريبه او بعيده اي وجهات فالوضع
هنا لم يعد يطاق انا طبعا استاذ محمد صالح
واحد من سكان المنطقه الذين اختاروا
التوجه الى مدينه الضعين في شرق دارفور
خشيه تعرض عائلته للموت بسبب القصف
المتواصل واملا في الحصول على عمل فللحياه
كلفه لم تعد متوفره في منطقته
لقينا البلد هناك ما افضل كمان بدنا نشوف
لنا اتجاه تاني
جنيهات معدوده في اليد لا تكفي فالبعض من
سكان المنطقه اشتكوا عدم قدرتهم على توفير
نفقات النزوح الى خارج المدينه بعد ان
قفزت اسعار التذاكر من 4000 جنيه سوداني
الى ثلاثين الفا وفقا للسائق جبريل عيسى
وصلنا الى 30,000 لاسبوع بتاع الحرب
[موسيقى]
الاشتباكات التي تدخل يومها الستين خلفت
وراءها عشرات القتلى ومئات الجرحى ووضع
اجتماعيا كارثيا بيوت دمرت متاجر اغلقت
وصيدليات بقيت عاجزه عن توفير الادويه
احنا
يعني غلبنا الشغل فيه وحتى لنا المركبات
حتى التواهين يعني الان ما قدروا يشتغلوها
ومع التوصل الاشتباكات وسط الامال بتوقفها
بل تجل ما يتمناه المرء في نيالا هو مكان
ياويه ويقيه ويلات الحرب فلا امان ممكن
اكثر من ذلك
توقف مع هذا الخبر العاجل مصادر العربيه
تتحدث عن مقتل وا
لي غير بعد انباء عن اعتقاله من قوات
الدعم في مص العربيه تتحدث عن مقتل والي
غرب دارفور بعد انباء عن اعتقاله من قوات
الدعم السريع نتابع ايضا مع الشان
السوداني حيث اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان الجيش بالسعي لاشعال حرب قبليه في
اقليم دار فورد وزجي مكونات الاقليم في
مواجهات ذات طابع قبلي وقال الدعم السريع
في بيان ان الجيش السوداني حول الحب ولا
الحرب من سياسيه الى قبليه بين مكونات
الاقليم داعيا مواطني اقليم دارفور بعدم
الاستجابه لمخططات الجيش السوداني بحسب ما
جاء في البيان
قبل ذلك هدد الاتحاد الاوروبي بمحاسبه
الطرفين النزاع بسبب استمرار المعارك وخرق
هدن وقف اطلاق النار السابقه واعز الاتحاد
الاوروبي عقوباته المتوقعه الانتهاك
القانون الانساني الدولي وعرقله عمل الفرق
الامميه في ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
المناطق المتضرره بسبب المعارك واجباري
اكثر من مليوني شخصا على النزوح وفق
تقارير امميه
[موسيقى]
الى موضوع اخر الان عن التوتر وهو ليس
بجديد طبعا بين بكين وواشنطن وانما
التوقيت هو حساس خصوصا مع اقتراض زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
المتوقعه الى اتصال هاتفي حتى وزير
الخارجيه الصيني الولايات المتحده على
توقف عن التدخل في شؤونها والاضرار بامنها
داعيا الاخيره لاحترام مخاوفها الاساسيه
انتقاد لدى من الجانب الصيني قابله ملخص
مقتضب عن الاتصال الهاتفي من الخارجيه
الامريكيه الذي اكد فيه بلينكن استمرار
بلاده في التطرق للقضايا محل القلق
بالاضافه الى مجالات التعاون المحتمل مع
الصين اما البيت الابيض فقال ان الحوار هو
الطريق الامثل لاداره التوترات بين
البلدين لكن مهمه بلينكل ليست بالسهله ففي
حال تمت زيارته كما هو مخطط لها هذا الشهر
الى الصين فستكون هي الاولى منذ خمس سنوات
بعد ان اشتدت الخلافات بين البلدين والتي
كان اخرها بالون التجسس الصيني الذي حلق
فوق سماء الولايات المتحده في فبراير
الماضي
منعطف جديد في مسار العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه
زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن الى الصين لاتمام محادثات
التهدئه
سبقها اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره الصيني
وخلاصه الاتصال واشنطن تسعى لخط مفتوح
وبيكين تتحدث عن صعوبات جديده
[موسيقى]
لينكن اكد استمرار واشنطن في استخدام
التزاماتها الدبلوماسيه لطرح قضايا تشكل
مصدر قلق ومجالات محتمله للتعاون
بكين حملت واشنطن مسؤوليات الصعوبات في
العلاقات بينهما ودعتها الى احترام
سيادتها ومخاوفها ومواقفها لاسيما بشان
تايوان
قبل ان نتابع ايضا نتوقف مع هذه الاخبار
العاجله الوارده من السودان مصادر في
الجيش السوداني تتهم قوات الدعم السريعه
بقتل والي غرب دارفور اذا مصادر في الجيش
السوداني تتهم قوات الدعم السريع بقتل
والي غار دارفور اي تفاصيل
سنوضحها خلال هذه النشره او النشرات
اللاحقه نتابع الان ايضا مع هذا الصراع
الصيني الامريكي ما هي الملفات التي تشكل
عقده الخلافات المتصاعده بين البلدين اولا
التدخل الامريكي في تايوان وهونج كونج
والذي يشكل للصين ملفا شائكا حيث ترى ان
واشنطن لم تحترم مبدا الصين الواحده اما
الاتهامات المتبادله بالتجسس لا تقل اهميه
في الخلافات بين البلدين لطالما اتهمت
واشنطن بسعرها لاختراق مواقع امريكيه
اضافه الى ذلك الهيمنه في مجال
التكنولوجيا تشكل ايضا نقطه خلاف حيث سعت
الادارات الامريكيه المت للحد من نشاط
الصين وتوسعها في هذا المجال عبر فرض
عقوبات عليها ما يقوض الانشطه التجاريه
للصين ويجعل العلاقات في مجال التجاره
مقيده في وقت تتنافس البلدان بل يتنافس
البلدان على صداره الاقتصاد العالمي معركه
شرسه اخرى تدور روحاها في مجال تصنيع
اشباه الموصلات حيث فرضت واشنطن قيودا على
تصدير التقنيات المتقدمه في الرقائق
الالكترونيه الى الصين في المقابل وضعت
الصين خطره تحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي امتلاك
تكنولوجيا الرقائق للنجاه من مقصله الحصار
الامريكي لمسيرتها الصناعيه
اذا حرب من نوع اخر تدور بين بكين وبعشنطن
للدقه اكثر حرب تحت اعماق البحار فالصين
بدات تزاحم امريكا في عالم كابلات
الانترنت اكثر من مليون كيلومتر من
الالياف المغلفه بالمعادن تعبر محيطات
العالم من اجل تسريع حركه الانترنت حيث
تسيطر شركات من فرنسا والولايات المتحده
واليابان وتتنافس في توريد وتركيب هذه
الكابلات لكن الحكومه الصينيه بدات في
اختراق هذه السوق العالميه بنجاح وفق
صحيفه بعد ان تمكنت الادارات الامريكيه
المتتاليه من تجميد حركه الصين قبل سنوات
بسبب مخاوف التجسس احباط طموح الصين في ان
تصبح منافسا رئيسيا في السوق العالميه
للكابلات لم ينجح تماما حيث لا تزال لا
تزال تبحث عن طرق لتحقيق مكاسب عبر
محاولات التحويل تركيزها الى المناطق التي
لا يزال لديها فيها نف تجاري والسياسي وفق
الصحيفه ففي اسيا مثلا حيث ينمو الطلب على
نطاق الترددي والكبلات التي توصل الانترنت
بشكل اسرع من مناطق اخرى في العالم هذا ما
تقوده شركه شاينا تيليكوم شاينا موبايل
وتشايناكوم عبر مشاريع الكابلات الكبيره
بما في ذلك مشروعان سيربوتان الصين
بسنغافوره واليابان من عمان سينضم اليه
الان الخبير في امن المعلومات رائد سمور
لنتحدث عن هذا الصراع الصيني الامريكي
الذي انتقل الى اعماق البحار الى اي حد
استجراد موضوع كابلات الانترنت وهذا
الموضوع او هذه الحرب التكنولوجيه هي التي
ستتصدر اي تصعيد من الممكن ان يحصل بين
الصين والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مساء الخير بدايه
حقيقه معركه الكيبلات هي هي جزء من
المعركه هي يعني احدى الجبهات الرقميه
التقنيه التي تجري عليها
المواجهه التقنيه ما بين الولايات المتحده
وما بين الصين يعني موضوع الحصار حصار
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها للصين هو ان
الحقيقه موضوع سياسي اكثر منه تقني محاوله
من هذه الحلف الناتو بالمعنى تاخير غزو
الصين لتايوان ومفهوم تايوان هي المقر
الرئيسي لتصنيع الرقائق وهي تصنع اكثر من
55% من الرقائق استهلاك العالمي للرقائق
فبالتالي خوفا من هذا الغزو يتم عمليه
المواجهه وتم عمليه فتح جبهات تقنيه مع
الصين لتشتيت الحقيقه يعني نوع من انواع
خلينا نسميه التكتيك الرقمي لتشتيت القوه
السيبرانيه الصينيه في اكثر من اتجاه وهذا
جزء من دائما تتهم الصين بانها تحاول
تخريب البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى اي حد قادر الصين
حقيقه ان تقوم بهذا التخريب لدوله عظمى
كالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قادره الصين قادره ولديها البنى التحتيه
التي تؤهلها لتكون قوه عظمى سيبرانيه
الصين من الدول المتقدمه يمكن ثاني دوله
على مستوى العالم ان لم تكن الان هي
الدوله الاولى على مستوى العالم بالحرب
السيبرانيه
نعم هي قادره وتستطيع ولديها القدرات
ولديها المؤهلات التي يعني تعطيها المقدره
على الاختراق والمقدره على تخريب البنى
التحتيه الامريكيه
الرقميه التكنولوجيه ولاحظنا احنا يعني في
نهايات حكم ترامب وبدايات حكم بايدن كان
في هناك هجمات عديده يعني لعل اخرها كان
قبل قبل اسابيع تحدثنا فيها ايضا عبر
العربيه وموضوع المنطاد وما تبع المنطاد
ومنطاد يعني ثبت بالضبط ثبت بموجه الشرعي
الامريكي
على
الجسم المتحده
لهذا التخريب ما هي التح التي تواجه
الولايات المتحده لمواجهه ذلك الان استز
رائد
والله شوفي يعني التحديات تحديات كبرى
بالنسبه لامريكا لانه البنى التحتيه انا
اعتقد البنى التحتيه السيبرانيه وهنا مش
التقنيه انا اقول عن الموضوع السيبراني
لانه اذا احنا بنلاحظ معظم الاختراقات
كانت تتحدث عنها شركات خاصه يعني اخر ثلاث
اختراقات للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تحدثت عنها شركه مايكروسوفت ولم تتحدث
عنها المؤسسات الخاصه بالامن السيبراني
الامريكي بالتالي انا اعتقد ان البنى
التحتيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المختصه بالامن السيبراني تحتاج الى اعاده
بناء لانه
فتره بايدن فتره ترامب العفو ونهايات فتره
الترامب ارهقت القوه السيبرانيه الامريكيه
وبالتالي كان في هناك اختراق استمر 18 شهر
لم يعني تنتبه له
الجهات الامنيه الخاصه السيبرانيه داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي
الصين قادره نعم قادره على
هذا التخريب وقادره على التعطيل ايضا
وقادره على الاختراق يعني بكل الاتجاهات
الصين نعم هي قادره على ذلك شكرا لك من
عمان الخبير في امن المعلومات رائد سمور
تشارك برلين واشنطن قلقها من تنامي نفوذ
الصين تكنولوجيا وبالتحديد في مجال التجسس
حيث اعتبرت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان
لينا بيربوك ان ضمان الامن في القرن
الحادي والعشرين يعني عدم التجسس من قبل
الصين عند الدردشه مع الاصدقاء
الامن في القرن الحادي والعشرين يعني
الحصول على الادويه الحيويه بشكل موثوق في
الصيدليه وعدم التجسس من قبل الصين عند
الدردشه مع الاصدقاء او عدم التلاعب بها
من قبل الروبوتات الروسيه عبر شبكه
الاجتماعيه
ومع ذلك لم تغلق برلين الباب امام الصين
تماما فالمستشار الالماني قال ان بلاده لا
تريد الفصل معين لكنها تتجنب فقط عدم
المخاطره داعيا الى مواجهه القضايا
الامنيه التي قد تواجهها بلاده نتيجه هذه
السياسه
لقد رسخنا هذا في استراتيجيه الامن القومي
الالماني بما ينعكس بشان الصين انها اللغه
التي تقول بوضوح شديد لا نريد الفصل نريد
عدم المخاطره لان الصين ستستمر في النمو
الاقتصادي كما يجب الا يضعف اندماج الصين
في التجاره العالميه العلاقات الاقتصاديه
العالميه ولكن في نفس الوقت علينا ان
ننتبه للقضايا الامنيه التي نواجهها
قبل ان نتوقف مع فاصل ايضا نتابع ما يجري
في السودان مستشار الدعم السريع للعربيه
يقول لا نستطيع تاكيد او نفي قتل او مقتل
ولغرب دارفور اذا مستشار الدعم السريع
للعربيه يقول لا يستطيعون نفي او تاكيد
مقتل والي غرب درفور سنتابع بعض لحظات في
اخبار الساعه ايضا في افغانستان قيود
طالبان تتسع لموسيقى او تصوير داخل قاعه
الزفاف او معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الساعه العواجل
تتوالى من السودان الان مستشار الدعم
السريع يقول العربيه نحن في حاله حرب ولا
مكان امن في غرد دارفور اذا مستشار الدعم
السريع للعربيه يقول بانهم في حاله حرب
ولا مكان امن في زمن
ايضا منذ قليل مستشار دعم السريع قال
بانهم لا يمكن ان يؤكدوا او ينفوا مقتل
والي غرب دارفور كان ايضا الجيش السوداني
تحدث
واتهم الدعم السريع بقتل والي غرب دارفور
اذا هناك تطورات كبيره في دارفور بخصوص
الانباء التي تتحدث عن مقتل والي غرب
دارفور طبعا خلال نشرتنا سنحاه خلال
نشرتنا سنحاول ان
نتعرف اكثر على تفاصيل حاله ورودها لنا لا
ادري اذا كان احد اصبح على الهواء لنتابع
معه ما يجري في دارفور نعود ونذكر طبعا
بالاخبار العاجله وهي عن الانباء التي
تحدث عن مقتل والي غرب دارفور ينضم الان
اليه السيد ابو بكر المحل السياسي من
السودان سيد ابو بكر السماني اهلا بكم
معنا ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل ومعلومات حول
الانباء لا تتحدث عن مقتل والي غرب دارفور
نعم تحياتي قناه العربيه تطورات تت
لاحم
ان في مجالات اخرى وفي مساحات اخرى تخرج
من العاصمه سمعنا عن مشاكل كثيره جدا في
مدينه الابيض والان هذه اخر الاحداث التي
تدور الان في منطقه تغرب مقتل والي
الولايه وكما اعتدنا دائما اتهامات
تاكيد سيد ابو بكر على مقتل والي غرب
دارفور
لم يتم التعاكيد حتى الان لكن طبعا هو من
قبيله المسالك المعروف انه هذه المنطقه في
دارفور وفي كل انحاء دارفور يعني المشاكل
الاسميه والعرقيه والقبليه دائما ما تتصدر
المشهد وتعقد الصوره اكثر واكثر هذه ايضا
القت بظلال اخرى تاتي في مرحله هناك تفاوض
في جده وهناك اقتتال ايضا ضاري جدا يدور
في روحه العاصمه المثلثه ما بين ام درمان
وبحري والخرطوم المسد يتعقد وايضا الحرب
تنتقل من منطقه الى اخرى وكان هناك رساله
واضحه وهي انه كلما تعقد الموقف في
الخرطوم كلما انتقلت الحرب وتعقدت الامور
في ولايات اخرى
وولايه دارفور طبعا نعرفها جميعا هي منطقه
مهمه جدا بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع
وايضا بالنسبه للجيش السوداني يعني هي
منطقه تعتبر من المناطق المؤثره جدا في
السودان وفي الحركه السياسيه وفي السودان
الان في دارفور بالذات ابو
اصلا هي مهيئه طبعا لمثل هذه الاجواء
بالذات طبعا كلنا نعلم ان الكثير من ابناء
الدعم السريع يتواجدون في منطقه دارفور
هنالك كثيره تتواجد في تلك المنطقه
المنطقه ذات حساسيه عاليه ويمكن ان تعلو
فيها وتيره التوتر بسرعه شديده اذا يمكن
ان تكون هناك اطراف ايضا خفيه لم نعلم
عنها حتى الان هي يمكن ان تستفيد من ما
يجري من من احترام هذه الحرب كلما تعقدت
وكلما ذهبت في الاتجاه الاشتباك المعارك
كل ما تعقدت الامور الان قد سمعنا ايضا ان
هناك قوات سوف تتحرك من جاد الى بدعوه
النشاط تحاول ان تستعين بتلك القوات
الفرنسيه حتى تحمي حدودها مع السودان ربما
نسمع عن ليبيا قريبا وافريقيا الوسطى كلما
زاد التعسر المفاوضات على ما اعتقد في جده
بين
المتقاتلين كلما ازدادت الامور تعقيدا
يمكن ان نسمع ان هذا الاقتتال ايضا له
الان جوانب عالميه ويمكن ان تكون هنالك
مصالح دوليه كبيره جدا وتنتهز هذه الفرصه
يمكن لاطراف اخرى ان تدخل حتى تساند طرفا
على الاخر المصالح كثيره جدا وكنا نعلم ان
هناك اطراف عالميه هناك اطراف اقليميه لها
مصالح في السودان رغم انه الوضع يبدو في
صورته العامه انه ماساوي وماساوي لدرجه
كبيره الا انه يبدو انه ايضا يشير الى
مصالح اخرى يمكن ان تستفيد من الماساه
وحقيقه الفجيعه الكبيره التي توجد الانف
هل يمكن اعتبار كبير
هل يمكن اعتبار بانه لا وجود للهدى بعد
نعم مساله الهدى طبعا هي مساله مهمه وهي
مساله منفصله يعني رغم انه يعني لا اثار
الحرب اثرت تؤثر على الهدن وتؤثر على
المناطق الاخرى في السودان لكن الملفين
ربما يبدو في مرحله من مراحل هم مختلفين
تماما يعني الدعم السريع يتواجد بمفوضيه
في جده مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومع الطرف
الاخر الجيش السوداني في محاوله لانهاء
الازمه اصلا ومحاوله الوصول الى ممرات
امنه محاوله يعني لتخفيف على المواطنين
على الاقل داخل العاصمه كلما انحلت العقد
قليلا كلما قلت الحصوبات خارج العاصمه
تاكيد مقتل والي غرب دارفور ما هي تداعيات
ذلك هل نحن امام مشهد جديد لهذا الصراع
طبعا المساله اذا لاحظتيها هي تمت بسرعه
وتمت بطريقه صادمه وحقيقه هذا المشهد ما
يمكن ان اؤكده لك هو ان ابناء المساليد
على الاقل سوف يكونوا منزعجين جدا وغاضبين
جدا وسوف يحاولوا ان يصلوا قد اوصلهم الى
هذه المرحله ايضا بالنسبه لحتى الطرفين
المقتتلين منهما وكما تابعنا يحاول ان
يرمي اللائمه على الاخر لان هذه المسؤوليه
ومسؤوليه كبيره ويمكن ان تلقي بظلال سالبه
جدا وكل الطرفين لا يحتاج طبعا الى مزيد
من المشاكل ومزيد من التعقيدات المجتمع
الدولي بالتاكيد يعني لن تمر هذه المساله
ايضا بالنسبه لهم مرور الكرام سوف
يتم التدخل لعدم
تزايد وتيره هذا الصراع اذا بحال حقيقه تم
تاكيد مقتل والي غير دارفور يعني لامتصاص
الغضب الذي يمكن ان يشكل في هذه المنطقه
طبعا في في هذه الاحوال طبعا الاهالي هناك
واللي جاءنا الاهليه وايضا العمد
والسلاطين والعقلاء في دارفور هم الاقرب
من حيث الجغرافيا ومن حيث الوجدان ومن حيث
ايضا التفهم لطبيعه الاقتتال التي تحدث
هناك لحساسيه المواقف هما الاقرب في
الماضي وقبل هذه الحرب كانت كان كانت
العاصمه
والسلطه في الخرطوم هي التي تحرك الجيوش
الى هناك هي من ترسل بعض الفصائل ربما حتى
تستطيع ان تحل الاشكالات التي تحدث في
دارفور وفي احيانا كثيره كانت تنجح وفي
احيان اخرى لا تنجح اذا هذه الوسيله حتى
الان هذه الوسيله اصبحت منعدمه تماما بل
اصبح كلا الجيشين كما نعرف
وبالمناسبه في في اخر اشتباكات دارت قبل
هذه الحرب تحركت ربما قوات الدعم السريع
الى تلك المنطقه ومن ثم تبعتها قوات الجيش
ايضا في محاوله ان في في
محاولتها لان تفك بعض الاشتباكات وبعض
المشاكل القبليه التي حدث في حدثت في تلك
المنطقه الان الى الطرفين هما منشغلان
تماما في فيما بينهما وفيما بعضهم البعض
فيبدو لي ان اذا هناك يعني من وسيله الى
ان تحل هذه المشكله هي اما ان تحل عن طريق
الامم المتحده او المجتمع الدولي او يمكن
ان تحل مباشره عن طريق الهاري وهذا ما
ارجحه يعني وهم قبائل ويعرفون بعضهم البعض
ويمكن ان يحاولوا ان يصلوا الى ما يمكن ان
يسكت البنادق وايضا يمكن ان يحقن الدماء
في تلك المنطقه والمنطقه عموما التي هي
ايضا تنزف وتنزف بصوره كبيره جدا خاصه في
الاسابيع الماضيه نتمنى ان تجد هذه
المشكله الحلوى الحل القريب لان هذا يؤشر
الى انفجار وكبير جدا في في منطقه دارفور
وهذه مساله خطيره بالتاكيد
على العربيه على الوضع الماساوي خاصه
للفارين من دارفور اذا تم تاكيد مقتل والي
غرب دارفور ايضا الوضع الانساني سيصبح
اكثر سوءا اذا هذه الاشتباكات تصاعدت اكثر
واكثر كيف يمكن ايضا او من يمكن ان يساعد
الناس في دارفور في خضم كل هذا الصراع
الدائر
دارفور تحتاج الى مساعده كل من يمكن ان
يقدم مساعده وايضا الان ارى ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هي تقدم يعني ما يشبه
الاعلان
لمساعده السودان من كل الدول الجوار ومن
الدول الشقيقه وايضا كل من يمكن ان يساهم
في حل المشكله فيها مشاكل تتعلق بالبيئه
ومشاكل تتعلم المجتمع ومشاكل تتعلق
بالاسميات والقبليات كل هذه ادت الى تدهور
الوضع الانساني بصوره كبيره جدا التقارير
التي وردت عبر العربيه والحدث كلها اظهرت
معاناه الانسان رغم ان الحرب كانت روحاها
تدور في الخرطوم الا ان اثارها كانت ايضا
تمتد الى الجنينه والى الفاشر والى كتم
والى كل تلك المناطق الموجوده في غرب ووسط
وجنوب دارفور اذا نحن بامست الحاجه لصوت
العقل من ناحيه الحاجه لكل من يستطيع من
[موسيقى]
نعم بالتاكيد هو صعب وصعب جدا وكما قلت لك
قبل قليل ان الظروف المناخيه ايضا سوف
تصعب وتعقب من المشهد موسم الخريف على
الابواب تلك المناطق تمطر في هذه الاثناء
وهي ليست لديها يعني طرق معبده ولا يمكن
ان يكون السير فيها سهل بالنسبه للمواطنين
او حتى اذا افترضنا ان هناك بعض المنظمات
الانسانيه والمحليه والمنظمات المحليه
التي تحاول ان تصل الى هناك ولا تقدم
المساعده فهي على الاقل الطريق لن يكون
ممهدا امامها لن تستطيع ان تصل تلك
المناطق وايضا بالاضافه الى ان هذه الطرق
هي ايضا غير امنه من ناحيه السلامه
الشخصيه والسلام الانسانيه لا تستطيع ان
تعمل على نفسك وانت تعبر هذه المناطق هذه
المناطق فيها كثير جدا من عمليات السلب
والنهب وفيها مخاطر وفيها بعض الجماعات
المسلحه
والان ايضا ازداد الموقف تعقيدا بعد
ابو بكر اسمح لي ان تبقى معي ساذهب الان
الى صالح ابو علامه الصحفي من دارفور لي
طلعنا صالح هل يمكن ان تطلعنا ماذا يجري
على الارض بالنسبه لموضوع انباء مقتل والي
غرب دارفور هل تم تاكيد ماذا لدينا من
معلومات
تعمل الاوضاع في الجنينه ما زالت تشهد
تصاعدا منذ الصباح
هنالك
ما ينشر ايضا عن اعتقال الوالي وايضا
ما ينشر عن مقتل لغرب دارفور حتى الان لا
توجد جهه تؤكد بحقيقه من قام بقتل والي
غربارفور الجنرال الخميس بكر ولكن ولكن
تاكد مقتله صالح
نعم نعم تاكد مقتله والفيديو المنشور هو
لشخصيه والي غرب دارفور خميس بكر فهو
معروف هنا في دارفور والجميع يعلمه
من خلال ما يظهر دائما
في الجنينه وفي مواقع كثيره الوضع في
غربارفور متصاعد جدا والاوضاع الامنيه
يعني اكثر هشاشه منذ مده طويله خاصه اليوم
ايضا هنالك انباء عن مغادره سلطان
المساليد
سلطان عبد الرحمن بحر الدين الى
دوله تشاد لدول السلطان الى دوله مع اسرته
يؤكد تماما انفراط الامن بمدينه الجنينه
بان الجنان اصبحت مدينه غير امنه تماما
وغير
اهله للعيش ولا تصلح ابدا ولا يصلح البقاء
فيها
لذلك كل شيء وارد في مدينه الجنينه بعد
الانفراط الكبير في عقد الامن وبعد
هروب عدد كبير وافرار عدد كبير جدا من
المواطنين من القتال لجوههم الى دوله تادو
ونزوحهم الى مناطق مزاوره بولايه هنا
اريد اسالك صالح بخصوص النزوح وخاصه الى
تشاد هل هذه الحركه ما زالت كثيفه
نعم ما زالت مستمره وكل شخص يستطيع الذهاب
يذهب الصعوبات تواجه الفري من القتال في
الطرقات حتى هم في الطرقات يعني لا ينجو
ابدا احد من عمليات القتل ومن القنص من
مجموعه من الميليشيات المتفلته
بطرق المؤديه الى دوله التاب الوضع في
مدينه الجنينه وضع خطير للغايه التقارير
التي هي فقط تلامس الحقيقه نسبه لانقطاع
الاتصالات في مدينه الجنينه حتى يعني هذه
الصوره التي تصل هذه الفيديوهات التي تفصل
يعني بعد سالنا بعض
المواطنين الذين يتواجدون الان في
قالوا بان الاتصالات التاليه يمكن ان تعمل
في مدينه الجنينه خاصه في المرتفعات
العاليه في
وهكذا يمكن البعض ان يستخدم يعني الشرائح
التاديه ليوصل بعد المعلومات ليوصل
فيديوهات واللي يوصل بعض الاخبار التي
ترشح منه من هناك من
الوضع الانساني طبعا هو سيء جدا صالح ولكن
هل يمكن ان تعطينا ايضا تفاصيل الى ماذا
الناس بحاجه الان بموضوع الادويه المعدات
الطبيه وصول الكادرات الطبيه بالنسبه
للمشافي او للمستوصفات هل قادره على العمل
ام هي متوقفه كليا عن العمل
فعلا هي متوقفه كليا عن العمل هذا هو
الوصف الدقيق ولا يمكن لاحد ان يقدم خدمه
في مدينه
الجنينه اليوم يمكن ان يقتل الشخص في
الجنينه فقط لان يعني لونه كذا او كذا فقط
لانه يرتدي يعني
ملابس قوميه معينه فقط لانه يذهب في احياء
بعينها او اماكن بعينها الوضع لا يسمح
ابدا بتقديم المساعدات لا يسمح ابدا
بالدخول لاول مره في احداث الجنينه تدخل
العمليات الغمس
كثيره لكن لم تشهد ابدا دارفور في تاريخها
انتشار لغناصه في المباني في الاماكن
انتهى وقت صالح ابو علامه الصحفيه
السودانيه اشكرك كما اشكر ايضا من الخرطوم
او بكر السماني الصحفي والاعلامي السوداني
اشكر لكم طيبه المتابعه مشاهدينا واترككم
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات